if we look at the Eagles as it hurts or
the team
I think it's a little bit of both man
[Laughter]
I think
[Music]
with the second pick the Denver Broncos
select Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP Von Miller
[Music]
welcome back guys this is the Von cast
on Bleacher Report
um it's always a great time always a
great place and this is going to be a
great episode because I got one of my
favorite players one of my favorite
people
um in the NFL not just in the NFL in
life Micah Parsons um he's a unanimous
uh 2021 Rookie of the Year First Team
all pro as a rookie pass rusher from
Penn State where he was a consensus
All-American currently making one of the
strongest cases this season to be
defensive player of the year
Micah Parson is my dog man
what's good man what's up my boy what's
up what's up you know um appreciate you
for coming out man I'm always in Dallas
and it's it's dope that we was able to
do this in person but um you know the
reason I am here in Dallas is because I
had surgery last week a week ago
um you know I know the last time we had
this Von Cass I said I was gonna be back
for the Jets game and you know I thought
I was going to be back for the Jets game
but you know life just you don't happen
um so I had already had like a um you
know a appointment to me with Dr Cooper
and just go over some things you know we
had a lot of options the non-surgical
route you know a little scope route
um or it was always a possibility you
know to go ahead and get this surgery
that I got and um it wasn't until that I
got here the day before that I got here
and I sat with Dr Cooper and um he was
like man it's about a real possibility
but I was telling them like hey give me
the best chance
um to like come back and play this
season to come back and contribute and
he said I go in there with the scope you
know if it's good and you know I gave
him because I trust Dr Cooper man I was
like hey man like wherever renowned
doctor bro if you get in there and it's
not right then go ahead and do it if
it's good you think I can come back this
season then just give me the scope but I
went to sleep and I woke up and I had I
had the you know the season ending ACL
surgery and um you know I really don't
have no complaints bro like I know
sometimes when you get hurt like you
just fall into like this this deep
depression which I've been there before
deep depression like you love football
you're not able to play football but
like I was telling you before the show
bro I do everything I possibly can do
during the week to have success I train
hard in the off season to do everything
from a mental standpoint from an
emotional standpoint you know kicking it
with the fam like watching film like ice
tail codes even the smallest things like
getting sleep and eating right bro I do
all of that stuff game week to give
myself a chance to have success you know
like we were saying sometimes you have
six sometimes you have success you go
out there you get three sacks you know
sometimes you don't have any sex
sometimes you you you know you get
injured and that's just the beauty of
this game bro it's a tough pill because
it's just it's just the beauty of the
game bro I love this [ __ ] though I I
[ __ ] love this [ __ ] and you know it's
not gonna be the end bro I'm already
walking walking
super powers like I'm looking at Vines
walking speed walking almost in terms of
oh you already had your surgery he's
like yeah a week from now I said you
walking already
I was mind-blowing I said well yeah you
know Dr Cooper he got me right I'm
walking
um you know I think you know when it
comes to surgery like this you know each
year they just get better and better at
it and they get more and more research
and more and more studies on how to you
know attack you know ACL injury or
whatever it may be to be successful and
it's just one of them one of them things
where I have ACL like injury and I want
to be I want to I want to not come I
don't want to do nothing crazy and come
back like you know as fast you know if I
if my body responds to it bro I want to
be that case where if somebody you know
unfortunately turn the AC I wouldn't be
like man what did Von do like where did
he go it's probably your mentality too
though bro you're meant to like I feel
like even when my body's hurting I could
convince myself that I'm not hurting and
I could go yeah that's what that's what
make us great past versions too bro it's
the mentality bro you got a A whole team
trying to stop you bro you can rush and
rush and rush and get stopped all game
but all it takes is that that one sack
for a small move say it again
you gotta have a strong mentality fam
and I think you know with me and with
you bro that's that's the mentality that
make us great football players bro I did
believe that I was gonna be back this
season I caught on my flight I did
believe I was gonna be back this season
I honestly feel like if I keep working
as hard as possible I could probably
make it back for the AFC Championship
games no I'm just joking man y'all man
now I want to get I want to get y'all no
more I don't want to get out of that man
I'm working as hard as I can man I'm
gonna be back as as soon as possible man
I appreciate y'all but while I was down
bro
um I always like to show love to to
people with my t-shirts whether it's
past players or or care players or you
know just anybody man and when I was
down bro I looked up I wasn't even
expecting it none of that none of that
[ __ ] bro and I see y'all like you had
popped it off first with Devon shirt I
was like damn bro that [ __ ] hard bro
like that [ __ ] was cool and like you had
all the teams on there and then like the
weekend games came and you had all my
teammates like with the jerseys I mean
not with the jerseys but with the shirts
like I be wearing bro like that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was love man I I ain't gonna
lie that was your first time wearing a
shirt pregame like that no I've been
wearing them I would say for the past
like five weeks before you even get
injured I had them made though yeah like
before your injury I planned on Watering
your your shirt before that because to
me like you just did everything right
you know Super Bowl MVP like and a
career haunted career sacks like I was
like man I idolized LT I idolize you Max
cries be like anything that I want to
accomplish in my career I was like
Vaughn has done it like man that's hard
bro you gonna be Hall of Famer I'm gonna
be at the ceremony yeah that's hard bro
yeah so like to me like uh when you look
at like excellence and you look at like
you know pass rushers and see who did it
right and then I watch you because like
when I first got to the league like El
Con is like yo you got to watch Ron
Miller
so when I started watching I was like
bro there's some like you do some
freaking [ __ ] out there I gotta add this
to my game and you know just watching
you and just still watching and just we
connected through social media and we
got up and I was like bro I'm a huge
drum fan like I tell everybody I'm a big
Vine guy your agent Dave that's like my
God bro like yeah you know he's not my
Asian bro but I go way back with David
since I before I got in the league bro
and like he he told me all about you man
I appreciate the love man that's love
man that's love man it's one thing that
I haven't got though that you have you
know a strong possibility to get is Win
Defensive Player of the Year you never
won that I never I never won that I got
I think I was I was second twice I lost
to Khalil Mack lots of Khalil Mack by
one vote I think that was in 2016. I
lost to JJ Watt my second year in the
league
um JJ White he just went crazy like good
I don't care what you would have did
like he went crazy that he went crazy
there JJ Watt went crazy crazy last TJ
watt like crazy you know it's just it's
just one of those Awards Bros it's
elusive bro like you got to be from
start to finish bro and it's all type of
competition man so you guys you got you
got a you know a strong possibility to
get it man I'm root young man I'm out of
the race man I'm root your own man like
you you're such a game-changing player
brother and of course I see the game
through like the same lens that you see
the game so to see you jump the snap
count and like stutter Bull and like
stutter spin inside and just like the
way you anticipate the game bro like
it's it's freaky bro like you know I
like I never say I don't like
comparisons bro I don't like doing
nothing like that bro but the way you do
it bro is you do it so dope bro and then
you know in your own ways like bro if I
could if I could do it like that I would
do it like the way you're doing it bro
for real I just look at like just all
mental like I just look for the first
win because you know how hard it is to
beat some of these tackles like the
first win when you find that into
weakness and you know you exploit it and
he now he got to figure out how do I
stop this and it's not nothing he could
do you know sometimes there's nothing
you can do to stop some and you just
keep exploring like like uh LC told me
you did like deferral first half you
just want to speed like you gotta feel
the speed yeah and then you hit him with
a spin stutter ball for two sacks in the
second half I was like yo that's so dope
so he helped me like in your game you
help me like game playing way better so
I was like all right bro I know exactly
how to like and the more I just went the
more I just like found my own way
through all your pastor bro it's the
game within the game like it's the game
within the game you talk trash like when
you going I want to beat you in silence
bro I don't talk trash either I got the
big pacifier mouthpiece and like I'm
listening to the call I'm trying to
anticipate the snap count but what I
what I do do is from an energy
standpoint like like I want them to like
feel my energy like if it's speed just
even if I don't get there I just want
you to know like if you're not on this
if you're not on this speed [ __ ] I'm
just gonna run around you and then when
you start trying to jump the speed I'm
gonna speed the power so it's just like
that inner energy like I'm talking I'm
talking [ __ ] like from an energy
standpoint like it's not nothing verbal
yeah but it's just like an energy
standpoint the only time I say so is
when they start trying to be extra yeah
you know the extra pushes trying to jerk
your neck up just because they sick of
you all games or like you know they'll
try I don't know especially the guards
they're the worst the ones that y'all
hit you when you finish a rush off and
the ball's already thrown or something
like that I'm like really bro like bro I
will tell you it like it it gets easier
like the more like you play it kind of
be like you know how Kobe like or like
LeBron or like any of the events in
basketball like a talk to the ref or
talk to the guys like it'd be like that
I just you know ain't somebody like you
know check me in the face and like I
won't say nothing because I'm not really
like a complainer or nothing like that
but as soon as I get the opportunity I'd
be like hey bro like you kind of hit me
in the face like you you trying to do
like that that's how you that's how
you're playing like you know what I'm
saying like nobody around like nobody
around it's just me and him I'd be like
hey bro so you you trying to hit me in
the face like what's going on like just
like on Like a Man level what do you
think next time when we rush where you
think their hands gonna be hands gonna
be right down on the chest where I need
them and I can yeah
sometimes you just gotta like you know
what I'm saying you know killing one
kindness like in between like the
timeout you know I go to the guy I've
been this is my 12th year in the league
so I I'm familiar with guys on every
single team so and I got a son you got a
son too right yeah and I'll be in there
I'll be like you know I'll ask somebody
kids like hey Halloween what you what
you gonna do like you're gonna dress
you're gonna dress your little Halloween
you make them feel good
is real stuff though like you know what
I'm saying it's real stuff to like you
know like just just to connect with them
like on Like a Man level outside of like
the football pads like yeah you know
what I'm saying like and then like you
know to hit me in the face like hey bro
you hit me in the face like you gotta
bring it down or you was holding bro
like you holding up there like that's
crazy yeah you know they're gonna bring
their hands down a little bit but I tell
you I did that to one guy I'm not gonna
say his name I asked him like bro you
hope you like you you hooking me he's
like yeah you right bro next time we win
he grabbed me right here bro like he
grabbed a handful of my jersey and like
was holding me right here like bro I
can't complain about it because you know
he took it out of my shoulder pads
because you know when they get you right
here bro it's like bro come on bro like
what are we doing it's flagrant like
honestly like I'd be really feeling like
the league be telling them like the car
no more holding pills this year like
they're at an all-time low I feel like
you're right they are like it like it's
bad like you're right and I think I
don't know I just think we getting too
good where they like we almost got to
help them a little bit or like it's
getting to the point where like it's
just offensive League we need them to
score I don't know which one it is
thinking about it and you're riff if
Michael Parsons got him Everton two
sacks every single game that he played
it's Midway through the third quarter
and Mike Parsons ain't had no second
just like something's got to be going on
here like yeah
let me watch a little bit closer like
something got to be going on here you
know what I'm saying so you know I
played a game with the ref too not like
no I just you know I talk to him like
Hey real come on like I know how it is
you know just like on a human level like
hey rap you know they out here holding
man like so as you get older real like
you you'll see those little tricks in
like the little ways of communications
people understand that trench warfare
you did bro they I'm not going live bro
I was when I was playing linebacker well
I'll play linebacker a whole lot last
year body was way more fresh but when
you're off the ball yeah
there's some place I wouldn't get
touched but when you're on the line you
get in touch every flavor yeah but it's
like it's just like hands it's just like
a little bit now it's different when you
got the chips and people trying to
condense down yeah you trying to fight
pressure against grown man like bro
that's different bro that's interesting
bro you say you was more sore playing
defensive end than off the ball on bro
oh my God see what's crazy bro I always
I was the defensive end that wanted to
play off the ball linebacker because I
felt like hey like if I'm a win
defensive player of the year I gotta get
the I got to get an interception I got
to be off the ball where I can make more
plays so I was always lobbying like to
our coaches like hey get me off the ball
a little bit let me let me move around
it's like you you like I want to be down
and on on the ball like I want to rush
more yeah I was like I I need the rest
let me let me cover when you tight end
that's why I like to drop back sometimes
because like sometimes like looks in
Disguise everything yeah so you see me
on the line a lot you gonna be like oh
well we gonna ID him we're gonna set the
protection yeah then we can bring
something from the field and then
sometimes I drop back into a hot tube
you know
but you know drawing straight drawbacks
some of these quarterbacks too good just
to throw rate to you and I'm like I
never get that well then I didn't see
him somewhere they just I promise you
gifts all the quarterbacks get nervous
and all the quarterbacks just throw some
[ __ ] I caught one on Tom Brady in the
playoffs AFC Championship game I'm
dropping back I'm spying Gronkowski and
it's really like a two drop but I had
when I dropped inside I was supposed to
man turn with him he ran like a little
uh seven rep I supposed to man turn with
him but I ended up like Zone turning
someone not Zone turned my eyes I didn't
I didn't know where he was so I just ran
to the spot where I thought he would be
and boom time just threw it straight to
me AFC Championship Game the biggest of
all games he threw it straight to me bro
I ended up tripping and I didn't score
but I ended up tripping and falling
bro there's a big woman too big pissed
down the leg well it's Tom Brady it's
Tom Brady though so you know all the all
the quarterbacks once you put their
pressure on them and you know the
Cowboys and Coach Quinn they do a good
job of moving around just from my
opinion they do a good job moving around
like from stunts having you off the
barber like they do a really good job
I've been in League a long time bro and
you know what they doing with you with
the Cowboys bro they ain't like that all
the time they doing a really good job
with you bro you know I'm a fan of it
man and shout out to to coach queen and
the guys what you know both it was a
crazy week
um this week in football
um both of our teams had crazy games you
know the Cowboys Texans game and the
bills Jets game like that it came down
to the last Drive which I really y'all
knew like they was going to go for it
the whole time or
like for my mind [ __ ] like and you know
because we play video games
uh a field goal not really doing nothing
like a field goal like even if they
if we go score we still gotta drive down
so I look at a touchdown I'll put the
game away so I'd rather score than like
just settle for the field goal either
way this momentum's gonna shift if it
gives us a chance to get the ball back
and take a lead so I get their mentality
of trying to finish the game like that's
the right call was it the right play
card debatable but it was definitely the
right call to me yeah I mean uh you know
Houston Texans like you know they
they're having won the most games this
season and you know you're looking for a
spark versus the Dallas Cowboys
y'all supposed to beat them by I know
we're not big spread guys but since I'm
not like watching the game I think I was
supposed to beat them like I think it
was 17 points it was some crazy [ __ ] and
they ended up being in the game like
late to win it like I'm in Texas I'm
going forward if you really look at it
like
um just off of us beating ourselves you
know they got the barn side the 30 two
three times that game Bill Trey had Trey
had a crazy fumble like yeah fumble
recovery like return like that game bro
like he started to go then a little he's
gonna go down and he went back that he
saw like one little crease because he
played receiver in college too right
yeah he saw that crease well that that
you know that that wide receiver stamina
once I saw three people in them I kind
of like floated behind him to see if
he'd pitch it back to me and see if I do
something again he's not thinking about
fishing he ain't thinking about that
right the DVDs that I think about
you see me start to run and towards the
end I just like let him cross back to me
now and I'm just like behind him
thinking he's gonna pitch it back
because we talked about it we talked
about it yeah like y'all been talking
about a couple times like in the locker
room where it practicing something yeah
like if you if you're in a position just
put your back
bro when the bullets flying bro I'll
tell you bro like he's now he think I'm
about to go skull probably if he's seen
you like a good viewer he probably would
have pitched that but yeah I'm like I'm
hoping he plays it back to be honest
with you well keep going bro I'm
thinking like man what are you doing is
he's just gonna go down that he found
that crease
than people think yeah for sure I mean
he played receiver he was recruited to
be a receiver at Alabama right yeah so
that I mean they show you right there he
saw that little crease took it I think
that was probably the most exciting nine
yard
recovery returns I've seen in a while
bro
um you know uh the bills had a crazy
game too for some reason like
well I ain't gonna say for some reason
because I always feel like the bills are
going to win every single game but just
for some reason I knew he was about to
win this one like with the rain and the
snow and I wouldn't say like like being
in Buffalo like this these uh these
couple of games and throughout this half
a year like you never get really used to
the cold or the win or anything like
that you never get used to it but I will
say
it just becomes a part of like who we
are like we the Buffalo Bills like you
gotta our mascot is the is the Buffaloes
you gotta we gotta get we gotta be used
to playing in the cold y'all have an
indoor coming though right no no I just
kept it outside yeah we got grass though
no we got grass on that that's just part
of like our advantage well that's part
of our advantage so I knew like when I
saw the elements and you know this was
just one of those games and Josh Allen
going to Josh Allen mode Diggs gonna go
in the digs mode and you know our
defense like whenever you like so I I
was down and everybody's saying like oh
what what the bills defense gonna do
without fun and then boom they like show
you like hey like this was a luxury like
this was a luxury like you know they
this is still the same team that they
was last year without me they was top
five and all five major major categories
with the same exact Team without me so
you know with me being there you know
it's a luxury you know you got to drive
a Ferrari I'm gonna do what I'll do it
man they still they still more than
capable man um you know Greg Russo and
Shaq Lawson and AJ epinessa and Boogie
Bash them and like man all the guys we
had we had
we had brick my dog uh Tremaine um
pose pose being All-Pro man I just knew
it was one of those games and that that
first drive I saw us like play the run
because the room was kind of leaking on
us the first time we played first
um first drive you see DQ split [ __ ] and
you see Ed and Tim and you see all these
guys get penetration I knew like it was
going to be on the minimum today man I
already knew how the game was gonna go
man and we we thugged it out and got a
win man it was a proper scrap indeed man
we came out on top you know that that
the AFC East is uh is a tough division
but the NFC East is tough too yeah yeah
now it's no joke we definitely ranked to
be the worst division
um
by a lot of people and to me we've
always been like yeah the Eagles always
been a good team yeah and you know that
I just got hurt in that system I mean
you see the difference it's made I mean
in Washington they always had a solid
defense now that heineke coming in and
scoring like that's a whole different
change and then they I'm not gonna lie
the bowl change that whole giant system
around and saquan is back to being him
man he
energy right system and healthy right
that's great that's better than him I'm
a huge fan I'm a huge fan of saquan man
the Eagles bro they I like to so I like
to you know I talked to you before the
show I was like bro I want to be a GM
like so I like to just look at teams for
how they built
um you know the Eagles offensive line
bro is just incredible you got Lane
Johnson you got Kelsey in the middle
like
um you know they got a whole list of
guys that are just as good as those two
guys that that back him up and then you
got hurts and AJ and you got Devonta
Smith
bro they got slay on defense and cops I
mean they somehow got Chauncey I mean
and then they went and got Quinn I mean
oh let me go get Linville soon like like
I
get together right there ain't no way
all right that was crazy bro I know I'm
digressing off Cedric man but like that
was really one of the me playing with
Aaron Donald where he came to the
password Summit like I've developed a
relationship with him before I was even
on the Rams like so for me to go there
and I had a whole list of guys that you
know Jalen Ramsey and Leonard Floyd and
Matthew Stafford and Cooper cup and and
Whitworth but for me and what I do like
you know great Gaines but for me and
what I do
me and Aaron Donald like even if we have
all those other guys we could have just
rode off into the sunset no I know why
it takes game Run exit game like that
was really weird did you see my uh my
tweet I put out just like I think I put
out like a month ago I said y'all don't
realize how much like value vom bring
like okay I did say that bro man no
because I'm I'm watching the Rams like
because obviously I was watching y'all
last year and I watched them without you
I was like bruh this man had just
changed a whole game because the more I
learned about the game I said bro you
need a dominant interior because if you
don't like I looked at like if I played
with like a Chris Jones or and Donald
like they gotta ID me but that means and
you gonna keep your eyes on me but that
means you can't take your eyes off an
air doctor yeah you can do that like
when I was with ad last year he got 100
of slide no matter what no matter what
we schemed up defensively like every
time we play A.D 99 99 getting a slide
so if if we had if we put three
defensive linemen on one side and ad on
the right side
they're gonna do three on three on our
side
on us and they're gonna put everybody
else on ad yeah you can't one-on-one you
like that's cheating that [ __ ] was
messing with bro you got the same you
got the same effect you wasn't in the
league bro so like the Cowboys before
you got there yet like Tyler been
killing but you like changed that whole
like defense bro just one drop of
Michael Parsons bro and it just go crazy
like best defense in one of the best
defense in the league second wise in all
top five categories bro I know I got
that in segment I know I'm digressing
bro like when it's time to pay you bro
it's gonna be like but I don't know
we're going we're jumping a little bit
reach out a little bit bro you bro
that's gonna be crazy you might get your
own team bro
Arlington Michael Parsons
everybody gonna be wearing number 11
quarterback everybody bro you're gonna
have your OT bro but bro you you do that
bro you had that same type of you know
effect on teams run I've been a fan of
you from bro from day one and then the
crazy thing is you almost ended up
a Denver Bronco bro like I know we took
Patrick we took Patrick's hand with my
god this is my god look you know bro
draft day was insane for me bro like it
was like that was literally the same
because I uh I heard that Vic like me
and certain and I I like Vic and his
sister his he even got bam brownie
eating this [ __ ] yeah and before Chubb
he was eating like they got a whole like
he keep a whole bunch of outside rushers
and when he took your turns like yes
because me and Pat was like yo it could
be like it could have been Broncos New
York Cowboys and Pat wanted to go to the
Cowboys yeah and we was both talking I
was like nah brother I hope I get go to
the Cowboys like that guys hey bro bro
that the draft was I think our draft
class might have been like one of the
best hardest draft classes I
you know you my dog man I love you man
but
that 2011 Draft class was crazy bro Cam
Newton me Patrick Peterson we had
Marcelo Darius TJ watt Tyron Smith
Richard Sherman Justin Justin Houston
but I think we're going to compete
though
look at Waddles during this year with
Tariq on the team I mean you look at
certain what he's doing I mean you look
at Rashawn Slater who's an All-Pro last
year before he had that Pet Group
Rashawn Slater's hard I love I love her
shots LaShawn slate is hard he I think
it's because his height he not tall so
it's really hard to get underneath it
it's hard it's harder to rush against a
smaller tackle yeah and he can move in
quick and he's stronger too I mean
rashawn's the real dead and I mean you
even look at uh JC horn that not since
he's come back from his angle I mean
he's been hooping this year not for real
I mean
Kyle Pitts I can't forget Kyle bro
you're running Fields look at what
Phil's doing now I think we we might
we're going crazy Fields uh yes Justin
fields in your class yeah Phil's just
pick 11. bro you right I ain't gonna you
right now you I wouldn't say you right
but it's you you have a great like a
great you know I think if we have a
great argument brother you all can
sustain what y'all accomplished in your
careers I think it's gonna be wrong yeah
you and JJ why are Hall of Famers
already
um but we can sustain what y'all
accomplished I mean we could definitely
gonna make the argument I would say this
two years in like y'all definitely like
bro it's a lot it's it's probably like
eight nine ten of y'all that in two or
two and a half years man not even two
and a half years one one to two years
that they're gonna be the top they're
gonna be the top player in their
position like starting with you know
he's a dog Patrick certain like I said
I've seen Patrick certain up close and
personal life I'm the president of the
Patrick certain fan club like this this
is he one of two players that I've seen
coming to the league that skipped like
of course you skipped you know your
reggae season two but these are guys
that I've seen with my own eyes
Jerry Judy and Patrick certain when they
came in like they just skipped being a
rookie they went immediately to year two
like and it's good to see Jerry Judy you
know have some success too because like
bro he is a special he's a special wide
receiver
um Patrick certain like bro he wears
size 13. I wear size 12 bro he wears
size 13. he could play nickel safety he
can play Everything well he just he
loves me fast but he line up on your
number one receiver like what like yeah
like
like when Pat got to go I wasn't even
mad I was like that you I feel like you
couldn't go wrong with some of the
Defenders we had yeah Jason you can go
wrong with JC horn like you Patrick
certain like so it was crazy like it was
just uh it was that that in the
alternate reality like the Broncos take
Michael Parsons and me you on the same
team like that [ __ ] would have been
crazy it's been so many alternate
realities where we supposed to be on the
same team we supposed to be on the same
team this year
and when I want to do is I know I'm
digressing I know I'm digressing a
little bit we're supposed to be that
same team man like me you Diggs law
D.A Diego man y'all guys y'all detox has
been going crazy
um Van Der ish behind us oh bro
Trey I mean bruh y'all got a a safety
that went to Texas A&M damn uh Donald
Wilson Donald my Jaguar oh my God like
he dog and a little bro y'all people
forget like Malik hooker was a top 20
pick in the draft like when he I didn't
understand his injury but now I look at
the hook now he looked like the same
Malik from college like bro I mean bro I
think
and death and like talent wise we got a
chance to really compete with anybody
yeah bro but it's all like when I tell
people it's not about Talent though it's
all about execution like you can you can
say we're gonna line up a b Gap stay
everybody saying they got been doing but
on game day somebody was swimming to
somebody else's Gap and leave a crease I
mean that's all it takes I mean this
league is just one play the what
separate good teams
um from other good teams it really just
be that mindset and to be able to
consistently do it play after play after
play When the Lights is on whenever they
get ready to like pull your card or
whenever it's your time to make that
play When the Lights is on the playoffs
and you can't lose like everybody
everybody name gonna get Cobra and they
take everybody in uniform fashion and be
like to step up to the plate and stand
up that's all they tell you of course
your stars gonna have to make players
like stars gonna have to make plays but
it really be the foundational players
that elevate the team it really be that
guy on kickoff return that when the guy
foreign attention he able to jump on the
fumble and save the you know the return
or like the offensive lineman that's
running down field that's getting extra
block so whoever can break free and you
know to be honest like every team in the
National Football League has players
with that ability but to do that [ __ ]
consistently over time when the lights
is on play after player to play versus
another good team that's what it takes
to you know really go out there and win
the ship man I don't know we got we
digress man we gotta you know bring it
back in man my dog my dog Michael man
that's love man I just wanted to talk
about you know just just you know just
entertain that that idea man like Von
Miller Dallas Cowboy with Michael
Parsons it was almost it's almost a
dream now like crazy why don't you
mention the draft like I almost feel
like God was hitting something at me
because I'm religious I'm religious yeah
me too I'm very religious but ain't no
way we could perform at this type level
with with no type of divine help bro
yeah you got we it's like 100 I'm
religious too but it's crazy like the
lady uh I was I was doing the new era uh
inspired change and uh lady was like
how'd you get your name
and I was like well my mom just woke up
one day out of her sleep and said God
please on my heart the name of Michael
like so like I ever since my mom told me
that like a whole bunch of other stuff
like I just knew like like I always had
a hand I always felt like I had some
over my shoulder like throughout
everything that's dope Brothers bro me
too bro like I ain't always played
um defensive end like I played a lot of
positions growing up and like you know
my dad used to always tell me you can't
hide Talent like it's always been my
dream and I always felt like you know
this was my purpose you know coming to
the league amongst other things as I get
older like you know my you know your
purpose you you steady figuring it out
every day but you're gonna start off I
was supposed to come to the league I
thought it was going to be a quarterback
that's my first position we'll use the
quarterback that's my very first
position for real the same one you think
if I was the same fun instead of at 200
at 200. I'm number four instead of
instead of 40 I'm four this is high
school field this is high school I got I
got uh some Junior High School film like
my version like like [ __ ] level yeah
no no it was only that like we was
throwing the ball like freshman year
like no it's like seventh eighth grade
we just knowing about it but it wasn't
Advanced yeah though yeah you go from
being a quarterback to to uh tight end
to like all these differences too I
played tight end I played uh flankers
like mixed between it's like a fullback
basically but more skilled you know it's
crazy about 100 like I was a running
back like yeah but like you could ask
anybody I grew up with like that saw me
play at like a Peewee Pony mentions
level that's like yo Michael might have
been like the coldest running back like
I used to be running like like that like
that's a real thing like when I was in
high school I ever used to touch down
like every four cares like that's crazy
like I like I was really a running back
like he was destined to be Michael
Parsons and whatever like it could have
been
it could be rushing to pass it could be
quarterback it could be you could learn
how to rush the passage that's the crazy
part like when I was at my first school
I wanted to be a running back and it was
like well we kind of already got it
running back you know how that is yeah
when you got your singers and your
Juniors ahead and this was that Central
Dolphin and it was like you either play
JV running back or you can play uh
defensive man I was like I want to play
JV running back I'm a running back yeah
and they put me on defense in the first
training camp I was like well we're
going to try a bunch of a whole bunch of
play you know how I did yeah and I went
I went and played I went over and rushed
and I'm talking I just felt so natural
like I was just stupid it's like you're
not playing uh
you're gonna you're gonna come play
defensive end over here and first game
our starting defensive end
broke his ankle damn I got no lie like
if we're crazy two two quarters I had
like two three sacks oh man that's cold
never lost that job six weeks later I
got my first scholarship offer I didn't
even know I had to go to college first
that's how crazy it was I was like I'm
going straight to the lead like I didn't
even think like think about it when you
come in a like as a especially like
where we come from small City like
nobody talk about college this is all
like NFL you know something like
straight out of high school I'm going to
the league like and then they was like
oh no you gotta come to school first and
then right I learned out the whole
process of the s.a.t thing and all that
other stuff that's crazy I was like
you're going straight to the pros it's
crazy but um I feel like I'm a running
back on defense you know before the show
you know we talked about like I just got
like this offensive mindset like I'm on
attack every single time attack attack
attack attack attack attack you know
they trying to stop me like offensive
lineman they the ones trying to stop me
and I saw
um a YouTube video
of Derek Thomas saying the exact same
thing like word for word like he was
like man I feel like I'm on defense and
offensive line they trying to stop me
from getting to the quarterback the
quarterback is my touchdown like he said
it before I like he said it before I
said it he said what I was thinking like
word for word for word and I was like
bro like boom this is my favorite player
bro like this is my favorite player like
he had already had passed away it wasn't
like you know somebody that I I didn't
have like somebody like in the league I
looked at the DeMarcus Ware but he
Demarcus is huge like Derek Thomas was
more like massage so you know to have
somebody that was passed like that had
passed away and I'm trying to mold my
game after them and like where 58
because he worth 58 and like do all
these things bro it was kind of freaky
so you know to hear you have like that
that running back mindset as a defensive
end too brought all the great pass
versus bro they they gotta attack Monson
on defense that's kind of how like coach
Franklin at Penn State so he was like
well we already got some ends but you
played running backs so you could play
linebacker and that's kind of like where
I like wearing like the same way you
talking about like they gotta figure out
how to like I'm maneuvering this thing
yeah so it like I kind of I kind of like
can anticipate so much more because I
played on the offensive side I know how
they want to block scheme things I
understand like how they want what gaps
they want to hit what's the cutback look
and it's almost like you you marrying it
like so I understand completely what
you're talking about like that's why I
say if you're the best player especially
in high school you should want to come
off the field like it hurts me I come
off the field so much in the league
bro you gotta you know you gotta be the
best Michael Parsons as you can be
rushing the pastor but I mean it'd be
dope if you could go if a guy could go
both ways I always had a dream that my
son right because I'm thinking like I
want my son to play quarterback and but
I want him to never come off the field
I'm like dang what if he played because
if you at defensive end they can always
find somebody from your offense Corner
they can find a receiver I'm like how
could I what would be the one to the two
positions that my son could be that he
would never come off the field right I'm
like damn like what if he was a cold D
tackle and then a cold quarterback he
didn't have like the typical like d
tackle he was like six six five two
hundred and you went from D tackle no
not me not me no no no I'm saying you
thinking your son to be detachable and
quarterback yeah never come off the
field because if you play any other
position if you play any of the position
they can find somebody else like for you
like if you if you want to play receiver
and quarterback that it never that
didn't have happened DB and quarterback
right that'll never happen but
linebacker and quarterback that never
happened but D tackle though D tackle
because there's not a lot of running you
can be in there you know what I'm saying
take on the triple Team Russia pass or
you know saying don't do every single
play you just rotate and rotate out and
then on offense you back the quarterback
I wouldn't go detack right like what's
the two positions in the league that you
can combine together where you never
have to come off the field
receiver in corner receiver and Corner
yeah bro that's a lot of running though
like I'm not saying never come off the
field but you could definitely play like
or you could play
corner and running back I think no lie
that's a lot I think running back and
linebacker now bro that's a lot of
contact Debo I think he built like a
linebacker he is he is but that's a lot
of cut and if you know if that's your if
this shows that's a lot bro like running
back they get bro they have they have
one at least contact every place not not
necessarily you know like if you're
looking at like see watch out watch out
Aaron Donald do it right let's we can't
even use Aaron Donald but let's say
let's say we had like
shopping I have to be quarterback in the
corner there let's say we had like a
let me think about my dog I think Lamar
Jackson to play quarterback he could he
could I think quarterback he could
corner corner not a lot of contact yeah
it's a lot more running but you could
carve down
say if say if it was a mix between say
peep this Ben were out this burger
and
Sue
like he was that that same size of
player but he was a d Taco like Sue but
then he was a quarterback like Ben
Roethlisberger two not two he wasn't
running all over the place you know
straight some guys oh if you combine
those two players that player would
never have to come off the field and you
break it down like that yes you know
there's not a lot of running I just see
there's a lot more like unfit the
attackers than our fit there's only a
few that'll do our dogs out there we
can't do it like that man like like I'll
honestly say like
there's only a few of them that I see
that's like really just like cut up
ripped solid 270 D tackles like but you
could be strong and physical like Sue
and then be strong and physical like Ben
Rogers burger and combine it too like
they're not running around you can't
there ain't no possible way like he
could just run around like Josh Allen
and do all type of crazy [ __ ] and then
come play D Taco defensive end you know
what I'm saying that shouldn't be tough
but if you combine those two players
like Sue and baron Rogers and be like
what are you talking about I'm just
saying like like body body styles and
body type man it could probably happen
what about the two players like receiver
and Corner that if you combine them
together they would never come off the
field Stefan Diggs and Trey Diggs yeah
they remember they both got the one of
the best ball skills they you combine
them both together and they play both
positions they never come on the field
yeah follow the number one receiver be
the number one receiver on offense
yeah that should be hard like that would
be dumb how much how much did you have
to pay how much would you have to pay a
player like that like just just okay
just expect just the speculation we
could put it like this
I think Trey he has the potential to be
the highest paid corner of this year
Diaz got the potential to be the highest
paid receiver
he he just got paid I understand why he
took I think he could be uh
a 30 million dollar receiver he said
yeah Diggs yeah yeah Diggs and you say
we'll say when it's time for Trayvon to
get you know cornerbacks probably be 30
million dollars too so so they both
making 30 million dollars so this player
would have to get 60 million dollars for
this player I wouldn't say 60 but I
would definitely range around
49 49 50 a year and you don't think a
coach would come in right and be like no
you you my Coalition receiver I can't
have you taking plays on defense or he
probably said are you my you you wanted
coaches DBS in the league like I can't
have you taking plays on offense
don't limit me like
like I feel like when you stay in the
Box it throws me off my game yeah yeah
like like
I've always and I told her I said if
you're gonna be great like just let them
go be great like don't don't try to like
don't worry about me unless like I'm
hurting myself yeah yeah so you feel if
I feel like I can like and you feel the
same way then let me just go be great
but then again we'll make a great coach
too is he able to like
you know he able to get the most out of
like his player and I'm sure like a
coach would say like if I can take a
couple of plays off from here you know
and have them focus on this
you know I'm sure some coaches with it
that's just that's that's tough to play
but just for speculation this player
will get 45 million dollars a year never
come off the field what number would he
wear Gotta Wear uno number one oh my God
yeah they got the chain this this kid
had to change and stuff underneath
exactly everything they gotta had a
visor you gotta advisor
um
like it got it like he might have even
got some wrist braces or something going
on too but that would be horrible I
think you just swag you like I think
that player he'd probably be more
popular than than my player of the show
quarterback to play D Taco but cold
enough to play just thinking if he got
sacks too though he got sex is big bro
they don't like defense bro hey you're
right bro this would be a different
monster I tell you what um
Josh Allen I wouldn't say he has like
a defensive like mindset but
he has I'm gonna run through you like a
[ __ ] he don't have he don't have
like an offensive mindset like like he's
not scared of contact would he prefer
contact I'm sure he wouldn't but he's
not you know to do it for his team like
he he'd do it you know what I'm saying
Josh is if not but probably one of my
favorite players in the league man Josh
I met him at the Super Bowl last year I
almost feel like he was my brother good
that's what I'm saying if I meet him off
the football field like like his energy
is like contagious like he wanted to
guys bro I haven't been around some guys
can you tell Josh to give me a jersey
please I want to get one like Josh like
if you're out there if you're watching
this like yo somebody clip this Josh
here this week trust me it'll be it'll
be at the position yeah I'm not even
playing like yo like
we digress a little bit let me let me
try to read it back in a little bit
Trayvon
he recently tweeted you know the hardest
positions on the field is quarterback
and cornerback I would I probably take
that a step further and say
those probably the two hardest positions
in all of sports you know if you think
about cornerback I'm guarding one of the
most athletic uh human beings in the
world
when Speedy wise Affleck jumping
stopping and he is he has a connection
with the quarterback I don't know what
they're doing I can't touch them after
five yards and I got to stop on the Dom
and still play the ball too I gotta be
I'm running down the field for you and I
got to turn around and play the ball too
like it's it's tough bro
you know the other position I'll put in
all the sports goalie goalie soccer
hockey almost both yeah bro for real
like bro just imagine like you at the
goalie you're a goalie game on the line
World Cup and you got a Ronaldo a messy
like coming at you full speed like one
of the most athletic frequency gifted
like soccer players in the world like
boom disclaimer I don't know anything
about going to say I don't want to have
I don't want to have any disrespect
towards any goalie in the world I don't
want to be beefing with the goalies but
nothing I'm about to say but I think for
hockey you don't have to like move as
I'm just saying there's more hand-eye
like speed like I got yeah okay I feel
like some of them is going in that like
like yeah 100 miles per hour almost like
in a disclaimer I'm not like I don't
want no beef or no ghosts more than that
like oh all right we might can take
hockey out but on soccer I said soccer
is probably harder especially because
they come fast too then again I want to
be for no hockey player like I got so
much respect for all positions this is
just what we're doing here on but we
don't have no beef with the goalies
around the world and hockey for sure
yeah
I want to say and if they're golden
soccer that gold and soccer bro is so
wide bro to get from side to side bro
like I just I can't I have to I have to
anticipate where the ball is gonna be
since you say uh quarterback like and
then and I tweeted this out too
do you think our quarterback is really
the most valuable player
quarterback because because they say
like that's the only like the MVP war is
based off of you know uh quarterback
play
and the quarterback Lee makes the MVP
but my eyes are like
uh and I you know what I I'm okay with
making people mad I I'm not a pro uh you
know I don't care about I can't make
everyone happy anyway like I can't say I
can honestly put some of these
quarterbacks in the MVP race like that
it's crazy to me yeah they're like you
know like we put I understand to God I
think right now it's down to two it's
down the two the homes in Allen Josh
coming back but it's down to two who who
else would you put I'll probably put
hurts in my homes
right now
into the season you know for me it's
hard for me to really speak on this Josh
right there Josh is probably here right
there in a couple weeks I don't want him
to make me pay
now I I put my GM hat on I'll put my GM
hat on bro it's hard like when you put
Talent around it makes it easier you
know well I okay because I'm like
Jackson you put okay Lamar he he almost
has his own doing it he's doing it by
himself and then Aaron Rodgers he went
he the highest paid quarterback in the
league not as much talent as he as he
used to having and he's not having
that's why I say Talent makes it a lot
easier Lamar okay are you good he could
do it by Rogers with Lamar speed does it
change
sheesh that might be the craziest
combination in football history yeah I
think Lamar Jackson he can throw he can
throw it he he throwing is good enough
to win games and to be an elite
quarterback yeah to be one of the
greatest quarterbacks to ever throw in
the ball like he has the potential to do
it is he that right now I mean he's
still working on it but what makes him
special is he can take any single play
and go to distance whether that's
throwing the ball whether that's running
the ball he can go the distance running
the ball he can go to the distance
throwing the ball you know will that
ball be you know for quarterback critics
will it be one of the greatest but it's
going to score you a touchdown you know
what I'm saying my in my eyes
can you say that if he's not leading
statistically or uh showing at any top
five category like is that an MVP I
think wins I think it wins I would say
the Eagles defense will be the MVP
I mean that defense is the offensive
line solid two no the offense is wrong
but their defense that the defense takes
everything to a whole other level
because you know I understand the
football
like it's complimentary so if the
Special Teams gets the you know we back
about to the net uh their 10 yeah or
their 20. that means the ball is getting
punted down deep you know you're not
putting as much height you're trying to
get more reach so that means we can
return the ball to about 60 50. so
they're starting almost in their
territory already so it's it's so much
more complimentary than football and
that's just and people gonna hate me for
it people Gonna Hate before I don't say
anyone I think as my put my GM hat on
to to build and develop a good team you
can do it without an elite quarterback
to be consistent you need to have like
one of these top quarterbacks in Elite
and you need to have a solid defense to
be consistent can you do it without
having an elite quarterback yes you can
I mean it's all type of great players
that can win games for you but the easy
route not the fastest route to winning
games or going to the Super Bowl you
need a top quarterback you need a great
defense I mean Nick Foles been traveling
I mean he's the Super Bowl champ so at
some at some point in his career he was
performing like top quarterback yeah
it was a point in his career where he
you could build a team a Super Bowl team
around him and he showed you that he
could yeah he Froze that guy I like
[ __ ] I like Nick folks me too
um but that's that's what I say but what
you said was Nick Foles at LEP that year
in the playoffs that's what I'm saying
but it just comes down to look
Brock
it's irrelevant who's about to bring him
up I mean Brock Oswald from uh from Rock
parties speak in the Box speaking about
30 speaking of Brock Purdy Brock Purdy
versus Tom Brady I'm a fan of bro I
don't even know bro
my bad I had skippedo because I don't
want to save us a time but we're about
to Purdy versus Tom Brady and I don't
know he makes it sound like it's if it's
Tom Brady versus Brock come on like it's
that's not really it like Tom Brady
going against the 49ers defense and
Brock is going against the Tampa Bay
Buccaneers defense and the 49ers defense
is is [ __ ] filthy bro like from
corner to corner end to end like so I
think you know Tom is going to have a
rougher day with the 49ers than Brock
you know had with you know the Tampa Bay
defense 49ers is surrounded with Talent
Debo IU crazy
McCaffrey Kittle uh kiddo now you see
Williams are we going to say is Brock to
MVP or is it the team that in that case
that's a team and Lamar Jackson when he
was going crazy this year winning games
by himself yeah Lamar Jackson that's
what I'm saying so if we look at the
Eagles is it hurts or the team
I think it's a little bit of both man I
think
it's system and team I think it's a
little bit of both man because they got
a great D they got a great offensive
line which helps hurts hurts has AJ
Brown and Devonta Smith they got a good
running game I mean miles Sanders they
skiing that they they skin that they
have o-line I mean all right bro like
it like and it's Eagles Cowboys the
eagle cowboy coming up ain't it yeah
it's coming up all right I'm not trying
to make no enemies I I just like I just
love the game so much and I understand
it so much that like
I can't I like I like when things are
off I just can't like hold it in like I
almost gotta say something like yeah
you're right they got they got a great
team great deal everyone has their own
opinions like but they got so Jalen
hurts is he's good he's good they got
him for the MVP race with Patrick Mahone
his status and what he's been doing with
the numbers that he'd be putting up is
MVP worthy just like what Patrick mom's
doing that Pastor I know we skipped over
a lot of us because me and you me we
skipped up with a lot of stuff but that
passed with Patrick Mahomes was nuts was
insane bro but that's what he does my
homes is an MVP and okay and we're going
to say this Mahomes lost his arguably
you said it was going to talk about
receivers whatever because we're saving
time he lost the number one receiver in
the league right now yeah and he's still
having an MVP caliber team he said take
my best weapons he lost he lost he said
take my best friend Tyree Houston going
crazy too he is without Patrick that's
what I'm saying so so same with Devonte
so now are we making argument is that
like because you know we we're the only
team we're not we're not dependent
worthy we're not dependent worthy you're
right so now you're saying Mahomes
arguably wasn't playing with a number
one receiver but he said oh well and he
still put up everything he's still going
crazy he's still going crazy he don't he
doesn't have agbrone he doesn't have a
Devonte Smith he did get Tony Tony's a
dog yeah there's Tony's a dog Juju is a
dog and uh Valdez but they're not Tyree
when they figure that uh cadir's Tony
thing up like I I looked up his
highlights right when they right when
they traded him because they traded
phones like
they went and got him I looked up his
highlights bro they call him the human
joystick no he's he's ridiculous before
he do all type of crazy [ __ ] and and
that and that Andy Reid like offense
with Patrick Mahomes like when they get
that going it's gonna be [ __ ] it's
gonna be filled it's gonna be filled
exactly with Travis kids I'm super happy
for Pat like because it's one thing with
your back on the wall they say oh you
need this person oh you need that and
the fact that he's having a year he's
having without that I mean Kelsey's
still being Kelsey like Kelsey's best
side of the league like but the fact
that he's doing that like without and
back against the wall there's like how's
my home's going to be without the
cheetah how's my home yeah and you know
there's all these critics and you know I
love him to answer I love when the
answer he's still Patrick Mahone still
Patrick yeah I I would say it's just a
different version of Patrick Mahomes I
wouldn't say he he better than what he
was when he had Tyree Hill or worse it's
just a whole different version and then
show you how great Patrick Holmes is
just yeah reinvent himself still be as
effective as many he had Tyreek Hills
when he don't have Tyree Hill like right
let's just show you how great he is it's
just like us we don't got to sit set we
just like damn bro like
we gotta go back into the lab and get
better I think if the offense don't want
you to have a sack bro I'm not gonna
have one all right
I'm gonna say you're not gonna because
they still made mistakes this I would
say it's a higher up it's a higher the
Oscar you get in the sack they go they
go way way down like yeah but you can it
still can't happen What so in my mind
when I'm not when not when they when I
obviously you go out there the first
drive and you see the whole game plan is
not to get you a sack I start thinking
okay they're not gonna let me get a sack
I gotta still figure out a way to affect
this game and that's if I have to run
down and try to punch the ball out if I
got to play Stout defense where I can
just cut the defense of hell where I
know they're not running the ball over
here like whatever I have to do to still
be that same
um Defensive Player of the Year type
player I got to figure a way how to do
it if I'm not getting sex I gotta find
another way to affect I learned that the
hard way
hey bro I I at one point I was like oh
this is so sweet I just stayed
one-on-one ain't nobody coming man after
them two set games in the beginning of
the year back to back I didn't saw chips
I don't hey there's times where like I
swear I got I get followed by the
running back I get followed by the guard
like they even try to move me inside I
beat the guard I beat the center and a
running back coming up and chipping he's
not even tripping outside no I'm like
yeah and they smart to do it because if
you don't then Michael Parson's just
gonna it's just gonna tear you apart bro
but what it do it make you when we talk
about the past for Summit like it just
make you that much you can you able to
um assess the offense you're able to see
formations you're able to see winning
slide coming so you can better predict
your opportunities to have sex in the
main plays it'll just make you that much
better that's why people don't
understand like defensive end is truly
hard because you only get three Ops a
game to really get a satellite you gotta
win those outs yeah if you don't want
the Opps you're gonna have no second you
know once you start once you start
whipping ass like and you get up by 14
21 that's when you have fun they go out
the window anyway everything that they
was planning to do it go out the window
and there was going to be opportunities
to get more sex but obj
you had him on your recruiter visit I
had him on my recruiting visit obviously
y'all was in Dallas we don't have no
basketball team to take them to a week
so we had we had dinner at Josh house we
had dinner at Josh house and um
you know we went to my crib and you know
we just hung out how was y'all how was
y'all visit with Odell in Dallas I
called him the next day and I was like
April what y'all do like we're like what
y'all did man I see you at the game bro
which I did I call him not as a recruit
like run a recruiter but just like like
fun like like bro like I want to see
what's going on hey I wasn't even the
original recruiter like I got a call I'm
playing Call of Duty I'm playing I'm at
the crib just playing the game I get a
car around like five o'clock the Jones
like Hey we're giving y'all floor size
seats uh we need y'all to take Odell to
the game
and the game starts at like it's like
two hours later I said all right bet let
me call Trey he said get somebody else I
was like all right man so I mean we just
hit the game I actually went to D
Lincoln then we hit the game I mean we
was just vibing get to know him like you
know I met Odell once or twice
previously through saquon but uh I mean
throughout the game it was cool it's
just Good Vibes like I got to know a
little bit about him and you know I was
always a fan over there like oh yeah
because humility is cool bro how he
approached the game his passion like it
show every time you're gonna feel and
you can't teach that you know so you
know after that we just like you said we
just found one what really made us like
super cool like for all the exposure and
like he one of the biggest athletes in
the world bro like when y'all kicking it
it just be y'all bro he really don't
have like you know it's just you know
he's so down the Earth he's so humble
bro like that's what my brother found I
thought he was gonna go to the Dallas
Cowboys but then he didn't I thought he
was going to come to the Buffalo Bills
but then we picked up Cole Beasley you
know I'm not sure I think obj is still
rich and everything know where obj going
now man we're watching while he's just
gonna end up it's going to be he's gonna
end up on the Super Bowl favorite team
right before the Super Bowl jaw dropping
yeah he gonna come back I wanted him bad
bro I came a lot yeah I wanted a bad too
but I mean you still never know man you
never know man you know especially with
Odell man like he don't he done made way
more plays with three fingers before man
so we just we just had to see here we
need a forehand you know but um you know
looking ahead at the playoffs like y'all
had the Tampa Bay Buccaneers that'll be
a tough that'll be I think all four the
Giants the commanders the Cowboys and
the Eagles all from the NFC West all
made the playoffs like that's ridiculous
Cowboys versus the Buccaneers uh
commanders and the 49ers Vikings and
Giants like in this playoff football so
I don't know what's about to happen next
like you know I can see that I don't
even want to I don't even want to
speculate but I will I see the Giants
beating the Vikings I see the 49ers
being the commanders my bad I ain't
trying to start no beef with the
commanders none of that I see the
Cowboys winning that one then the
Cowboys gonna play
uh the 49ers next and then the Eagles
play the Giants
then I see the Eagles beating the Giants
again and then I see the Cowboys beating
the com the 49ers then I got the Cowboys
versus the Eagles and I got the Cowboys
beating the Eagles in the NFC
Championship Game and going to the Super
Bowl to play the
Buffalo Bills in the Super Bowl and that
one we're just gonna have to see man we
just got to see that one
it's gonna pay me to go against Josh
it's gonna hurt me right I'm so glad I'm
on his team like because when I gotta
say every time I play Josh you know I
got a sack on you know every time I play
every time I play you know Josh I got a
sack you know
Dawkins you know you know a big dog I
beat I beat Dion Dawkins like
give me give me uh
what's the game playing as Dion let me
know you know I tell you what like and
this is I'm not even guessing I'm gonna
tell you the truth like
Deanna he's so well around it you know
we talked about like smaller tackles not
he's not necessarily smaller because he
heavy but he
he they say 340 pounds but he probably a
little bit heavier than that bro we call
him a slow man and he can move and he
athletic and all of that stuff so he can
he jump out there in your speed but then
he sit down on the speed of power so
it's like those little you know
intrinsic like movements like coming
from speed to power but to spin inside
you know those might be you know he
honestly don't have no vulnerabilities
but just man oh man like spart all all
you gonna win something he gonna win
soon yeah man he coaches like you cold
and just over time like y'all going
Y'all Gonna spark luckily we got Josh
Allen and you know he gonna you know I
make magic he know how to scramble and
you know get around
I got I got if he gonna if I'm gonna do
the AFC I got Chiefs over Patriots
I got dolphins
Chiefs Chiefs Patriots
I like Bengals over Titans again
Bengals over to Titans
um
Joe Bird yeah I like bear bird like Joe
bear Joe bird chase he's
T boy mix oh
and then who oh yeah Bill's dolphins
that rematch oh man man I ain't even
playing but we're about to start
you know that's like little brother he
ain't little brother call it Big Brother
come fight man I'm gonna call my brother
on y'all I ain't even playing this week
I don't think we're gonna beat him
bro I there's just no answer for uh
Tyrese a model right now bro
yeah it feels
I ain't gonna lie when we played them
when we played them early in the season
you know we had some success versus
though we lost but we had some success
and I think to be the NFL team twice is
super tough bro it is still but this is
the playoffs we would already won one
they won one this would be our third
game two
if two is on point where I've seen
honestly I think the bill I could
honestly dolphins being the AFC
champions this year
with their weapons they got and the
defense they got hold on I just went to
the NFC thing I went all the way bro I
told you I'm a realist I can't make
everybody happy you my dog you're my dog
but I look at this Tyree in this waddle
match man I could have said the eagle I
know and I will understand
but if it's not the Dolphins I like the
bill
if it's not the Dolphins I got the bills
it's going to be the winner between the
bills and the Dolphins that's going to
be the champion they got a tough matchup
this week here in Buffalo coming up so
that'd be a little precursor to this
playoff game man I got a number of
respect to the Dolphins they beat us
um number of respect him I got Michael
Parsons man all love and respect man
it's been an honor and a privilege man
like you know come on my Von cash and do
with me man if you ever need me for
anything man if that's you know anything
Zoom uh text somebody call it man you
got me bro I'm I'm locked in forever
with you man I appreciate you man that's
all right man I appreciate you man
that's all I love man get up for Michael
Parsons my God man
that's this week's Von cash all love and
respect I appreciate y'all